Film Courage: And I think who you watch a
movie with in a theater plays a big role [in
how you see the movie].
I remember watching a film and the only other
person in the theater (and it was at night)
was a celebrity (I won’t say who it was).
But they were there to support the filmmaker
and that person was laughing and I found myself
laughing quite a bit, too.
And then I thought “Wait a minute.
Am I just trying to join in with this person?
Is this why I am laughing?”
However, it was a great experience.
And it was surreal being in this huge theater
with the one famous person watching this film.
Daniel Stamm: Was it Quentin Tarantino?
Film Courage: It was not.
I can say that.
Daniel Stamm: [Laughing] Because I have seen
him laugh through a movie of mine that wasn’t
supposed to be funny!
But he had such a good time.
I don’t know if that’s a good thing or
bad thing?
But he was laughing from the first to the
last minute.
And I was like “What does that mean?”
And you could tell that the rest of the audience
was confused because he has a very succinct
laugh.
You can tell it’s Tarantino.
Film Courage: Right…Daniel Stamm: So if
he thinks it’s funny then people are probably
wondering “Should I think it’s funny?”
and there is a weird energy throughout the
movie.
And it’s just really interesting that it
probably has to do with that dynamic again,
the group dynamic…that there is a desire
to be on the same page with your fellow human
beings, kind of thing.
And I think that is why everyone an audience
is kind of trying to have the same experience
and not be too far off from the tribe.
That is maybe why comedies work so much better
with a big audience rather than a small audience
because there is less confusion.
So it’s like everyone else is having fun
so I should have fun, too.
And the subconscious tendency toward that.
Film Courage: And you never got an answer
as to why certain parts [of your movie] were
funny?
Daniel Stamm: To the Tarantino thing?
Film Courage: Right.
Daniel Stamm: I talked to him afterwards and,
well you know how he talks [imitating high
energy] and all this stuff.
But I don’t think I got a word in to ask
what he thought was funny.
Film Courage: I know sometimes if we go to
a theater to watch a movie and it’s usually
a mainstream film that is [at a chain theater]
in more of a sort of bedroom community and
these aren’t people in the industry, what
I’ll do is I’ll clap at the end [of the
movie] to see how many people will clap with
me.
Because usually when you go to a Hollywood
film or something around this [Los Angeles]
area, people are all in the industry or they
know someone who is and they realize the hard
work that the people behind-the-scenes put
in….and they will clap at the end.
I’m surprised (and sometimes David teases
me) at how many people don’t clap afterwards.
And they just get out of their chairs, groan
and are like “Okay…What’s next?
Where do we go get cake and coffee after this?”
I find that interesting because [applause
at the end of a film] is so dependent on the
area in which you see it.
Daniel Stamm: I’ve had that with flights.
You know how some people clap after the plane
lands?
Film Courage: [Laughing] Yes….we made it!
Daniel Stamm: Right.
When I first heard this I thought “Maybe
this is an American thing?”
because I think I was 35 years old when I
first set foot on a plane where people are
clapping and I was like “What did people
expect?
Are we celebrating this outcome?”
And it’s kind of the same (I think) with
a movie.
That you expect the filmmakers that have had
a budget of millions of dollars and the audience
has just each paid their good money to see
that story.
They take it as a given that they are being
given a good time over those two hours.
They feel like they shouldn’t have to celebrate
that they weren’t screwed over and robbed
of their money.
So I can understand the mindset of not clapping
after a movie.
And I actually have that when the movie was
really good, I can’t clap or worse…. even
talk to people afterwards.
Like if you are really affected by something,
it goes so far.
You’re in a different place.
You’re not clapping.
Like if you’re clapping, the movie hasn’t
100% gotten to you.
Maybe if it’s a comedy, that’s a different
thing.
But if it’s Lars Von Trier's 'Breaking the
Waves.’
If that got you afterwards, you would not
clap.
Because clapping means you are aware …. like
you were saying …. aware of the work that
has been done.
But if the work has been done brilliantly,
you’re not even aware of the work that has
been done, you’re just flattened by the
story and the characters that you’ve just
experienced.
You don’t think about directors, writers,
cinematographers, stunt men.
All the stuff behind the scenes because you’re
so impressed by the narrative that you’ve
just experienced.
I didn’t know I felt this way about clapping
until we just talked about it.
But, that is maybe why I can understand why
people don’t clap.
I don’t know if for one of my movies I would
rather have people clap or not clap?
I know for my first movie it was this fake
documentary about suicide.
No one ever clapped after that movie.
And I would have known that I would have failed
if they clapped after that movie.
Whereas with the other movies, where it was
more of an upbeat ending or at least not that
dark, it probably would have been okay for
people to clap.
Which they did’t either.
Maybe I’m just making bad movies?
I don’t know what it is?
I don’t experience the clap.
That is, outside of a festival audience.
I think at festivals because people assume
that some of the filmmakers are attending
and it is kind of polite to clap but I don’t
think I’ve ever experienced the audience
was clapping at one of my movies?
Film Courage: That would make an interesting
survey for artists that make films.
Would you be offended if someone clapped after
your movie or would you take it as a compliment?
Daniel Stamm: It depends on the movie.
It depends on the state you want to put people
into.
Going back to David Fincher’s movie, at
the end of SEVEN, whether people are clapping
or not clapping and whether you want that.
It probably depends on the story you were
just telling and the emotion you were hoping
to put the audience into.
Fincher, it could be because we just had that
example earlier for SEVEN, you want to the
audience to be so distressed and destroyed,
that he probably wouldn’t want anyone clapping
at the end of the movie.
I think he would have known at the test screening
that something is wrong with this movie.
Whereas there are probably other movies that
are more upbeat and have a different energy.
Film Courage: True….and I am thinking back
to the [movies] that I’ve clapped at recently
and they were not….these sort of…melancholy
endings.
So, that does make sense.
Question For the Viewers: Do you ever clap
at the end of a movie?